superhero fatigue is not the problem
crap movies and TV shows is the problem
welcome to side track your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so yes I have seen DC's Blue Beetle and
I think it's fair to say
they've done it again right so the DC
makers basically thought people quite
like Spider-Man let's do Spiderman
people quite like the first shazam movie
the first one not the second
so let's do a Shazam type of movie and
let's talk about family a lot because
you know they've got 10 of those Fast
and the Furious movies and they talk
about family all the time there's always
room for family
we're family I know you guys are a
family so I'm offering you a chance
right now to make that family whole
again you want to make this family whole
again
let's throw a sprinkling of Green
Lantern in there as well you know just
because
that'll be a great movie people will
love that we'll have a massive CGI
battle that you can't tell what's going
on at the end and then people will go
crazy and will make a billion dollars
it's had the lowest opening weekend of
any DC movie for 10 years and that is
saying something because a lot of DC
movies are not very good the Shazam
sequel was a hot mess actually pretty
much everything they've done has been
uh questionable I personally loved Man
of Steel and I personally really love
Batman vs Superman
but let's be honest there are massive
problems of both
and let's be honest as well Marvel are
also seriously struggling because I
finished watching secret Invasion last
week and my God what the hell were they
thinking
so we've got the amazing Nick Fury
played by Sam Jackson who is amazing
they basically decided to make Nick Fury
a pathetic old man they then youngified
him and found out that actually he was
quite a pathetic young man and if it
wasn't for the scroll we wouldn't even
know Nick Fury was and then they
basically had this weird DNA thing at
the end and a big fight that made no
logical sense
the problem I have is that Marvel were
always really really good basically
until the end of the infinity War Saga
are just stepping up to the ridiculous
but never crossing the line they always
made the superhero movie
on some levels believable even when it
obviously wasn't
they never wandered into the realm of
silly
but in recent years they seemed to have
forgotten how Ant-Man quantumania stuff
danced all over the silly
surprised to see me
yeah
a lot of thunder
oh my God that was just creepy in places
it was ridiculous in others
didn't make much logical sense in places
as well the jokes were just like comedy
vomit that didn't really hit the mark at
all and really
when did Thor become a complete dumbass
they basically had Thor Ragnarok for me
probably the best Marvel movie ever it
is maybe my favorite
and they just pistol over it and they
completely said no people really like
the humor let's have more
take away TT I actually think is a
really interesting director but they let
the shackles off him they let him just
go crazy with it because they trusted
him because of what happened at Ragnarok
and
he ruined it too much tanker for the
Marvel
way way too much tiger on the screen but
I mentioned the TV series
Marvel hasn't really done a good one I
would say Hawkeye was okay it's a bit
dull but it was okay I would say Miss
Marvel I watched one episode and
couldn't be bothered to watch rest
She-Hulk was a complete waste of time if
you actually watch the final episode and
think about it nothing happens except to
unravel everything you've already
watched so complete waste of time Loki
was actually pretty good in places but
meandered towards the end Moonlight was
a hot mess from beginning to end it was
it was one of those TV shows that if you
blinked or sort of like looked at your
phone for a second or whatever and
looked back up
why is a massive hippo talking to him
and there's just no idea what the hell
has just happened
it was also a little boring and then I
got two 14 year old kids here and they
wouldn't watch it so that should really
tell you everything because really
that's Marvel's demographic I know it
tends to be 40 year old men but
really it should be 14 15 year old boys
and they can't even keep them interested
DC have maybe made one decent um
superhero movie for me and that's Shazam
I know people love Aquaman but to be
honest I love Jason Momoa I didn't love
the movie
I haven't really enjoyed any of their
forays into the superhero movie and
Suicide Squad particularly the second
one it's one of the worst movies I've
ever watched so DC creating Blue Beetle
which was just derivative and basically
them trying to cherry pick from other
movies and thinking that that would make
some sort of hybridized brilliance
is just a joke
we have people like James Gunn telling
us that The Flash movie was the greatest
superhero movie you'd ever seen
I actually am very worried about DC's
future if they genuinely believe that
other than maybe the most recent Batman
movie which again if they took about 30
minutes out of it would have been a
really good film it was a bit too long
and a bit too drawn out in places
other than that everything they seem to
be doing is just awful
Peacemaker I actually loved but I am in
the minority it seems a lot of people
really hated it
again though it may be just because I
love John Cena I'm not sure so the
problem is not superhero fatigue
even though yeah okay we do seem to be
getting tired of it but I would say
we're getting tired of it because what
Marvel and DC have been producing is
crap and that's the problem that's the
fatigue we're exhausted of the rubbish
basically for Marvel since the Russo
Brothers actually finished the Thanos
Saga they've really not had a Direction
they don't really seem to know where
they're going they always had the
infinity Wars as the end goal and it
seemed to keep them on track we were
going to have this new Saga book the
actors Antics seem to have ruined that
so they seem to be meandered they seem
to be almost fearful of superhero
fatigue and trying to do things that are
different to try and you know maybe
avoid it but by doing things that are
different unfortunately they've done
things they're just not good they just
have lost their Mojo but I keep
expecting them to fix it I keep
expecting carrying fire to go come down
and between a bricks go right I've
let you lot run the roost now I've let
you little kids run around but now I'm
getting back in charge and I'm gonna get
this sorted
secret Invasion came out and I genuinely
believed that was going to be them
getting back on track
and it was rubbish Doctor Strange too
really should have been a no-brainer and
it was rubbish Marvel only seemed to be
able to make a good film if they're
making it with somebody else
Sony have dragged three really good
Spider-Man movies out of them they can't
make a Venom movie to save their lives
so really I am concerned about the
superhero genre I really think we are
currently in a dark age for it and I'm
just hoping that maybe James Gunn can
save it for DC
and that Kevin FEI really does come down
and kick some ass and get them back on
track we need less superhero movies we
need less superhero TV shows and they do
seem to have heard that they do seem to
be trying to slow down the calendar a
little bit and giving us a little bit
less
there has been way too much quantity and
not enough quality and you can see that
in the CGI just look at the flash the
CGI is an absolute joke and it's because
they're underpaid overworked and don't
have time to actually finish the job
the CGI is a symptom of a much bigger
problem
a problem that Marvel and DC really
really need to sort out because their
parent companies Warner Brothers and
Disney in the case of Marvel need them
to desperately
and if they don't the parent companies
are really going to have problems and as
consumers we're gonna lose out on
something that we dearly love because
let's be honest a good superhero movie
that's the summer blockbuster you want
and I just feel like
we might not get many in the future
but let's hope if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification when it helps us out
so you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and you get
to see them without the adverts before
everyone else for a small contribution
each month that really helps the channel
also you can go to sidetrack.co.uk which
is our dedicated website storage related
to all of our videos appear there and we
you know add a little bit more content
for you know that meat on the bones for
you to chew on so please go and check it
out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]